the Milky Way a spiral galaxy full of
regions of gas and dust called nebulas
and everyone has their favorite I really
like the Horsehead Nebula it just looks
awesome the cat's eye nebula has always
been really captivating to me my
favorite nebula is the Orion Nebula the
Orion Nebula is perhaps the best place
to understand the evolution of stars and
it's right here in our own backyard the
Orion Nebula is maybe one of the most
famous nebulas because you can go
outside at night and see it with your
own eyes humans have been observing this
fuzzy patch of sky for centuries the
Maya of Central America called it the
fire of creation the Maya were more
right than they knew almost every part
of the life cycle of a star you can see
in a nebula
we can't understand the life cycle of
stars without understanding the life
cycle of nebulas they are intertwined
Orion has it all from massive stars on
the brink of death to newborn stars
swaddled in gas you see the intricate
wisps of material the thin veils
enveloping newborn stars pillars
colliding into each other you see stars
plowing through clouds of gas you see
this frenzied hive of activity operating
right before our eyes in 2018 using new
data NASA creates a groundbreaking 3d
visualization of Orion's interior for
the first time in history we have the
right tools to actually explore the
hearts of these nebulas it was already
beautiful to begin with but now we have
even more vivid images to really
appreciate how great of a structure this
is an Orion's heart lies a cluster of
young stars together they blast out
charged particles and solar winds
blowing open a gap at the center
creating a window inside
we actually see the structures in the
volume we can actually see the processes
happening right before our eyes
[Music]
the clusters intense starlight energizes
the surrounding gas causing it to glow
pink and blue the Pink's come from light
emitted from hydrogen atoms in the
nebula glowing like the gas in Ernie on
tube the Blues tend to come from the
light from the hot new stars reflected
off of dusts particles these hot new
stars illuminate the Orion Nebula but
they were actually born in the dark one
particular type of nebula is a dark
nebula and basically that's when the
concentration of dust is a lot greater
dense clouds of dust block out visible
light from the stars behind creating
shadowy shapes like the Horsehead Nebula
this nebula is so large and dense it has
enough mass to make about 30 stars the
size of our Sun and now astronomers can
peer inside only recently have we been
able to start doing this
thanks to detectors that can see light
in the infrared
the infrared allows us to sort of see
through the dust of a nebulae and see
what's going on deep in its heart humans
can't see infrared light but we can't
feel it as heat infrared detectors tell
us these dark star-forming clouds are
cold hundreds of degrees Fahrenheit
below freezing
but deep inside our hot spots
[Music]
if you look at with infrared you see ah
the signature of incredible densities
and incredible temperatures the signs
then a new stars being born
a nod if matter comes together under the
force of gravity
as it grows so does the gravity it pulls
in more gas growing bigger and bigger
that gets very massive very dense and
very hot eventually it gets high enough
pressure and temperature in the center
of that object that you ignite fusion a
star is born
one of the hundreds of billions that
make up our galaxy the latest in a
stellar production line going all the
way back to the dawn of time and the
very first nebula if we want to unravel
the history of the Milky Way we want to
start in the beginning and that's the
Big Bang
13.8 billion years ago the universe
sparks into life
at first it's pure energy but over
300,000 years that energy cools into
hydrogen and helium gas back then the
entire universe was one enormous cloud
the essential ingredients of our
universe spread as the universe expanded
and so the universe started as one giant
nebula over time the primordial nebula
starts to collapse and fragment into
smaller clumps these regions become so
dense that collapse into disks with
super hot balls of gas in their cores
the first stars ignite they start out as
nearly pure hydrogen but as they age
they make other heavier elements stars
forge new elements that's what they do
the very definition of a star is in its
core it's fusing hydrogen atoms into
helium and releasing energy but many of
those first simple stars were massive at
massive stars don't live for long they
burned through their supply of hydrogen
incredibly rapidly and they burn
themselves out and they died after a few
million years they go out with a bang
an explosion that releases more complex
elements back into the primordial nebula
after that first generation of stars
started to form there was this huge
burst of new elements that formed and
that were dispersed throughout the
universe to be able to form that next
generation of stars as the second
generation of stars lives and dies it
adds even more ingredients to the cosmic
mix the next generation of stars fuse
more elements exploded died spread the
material new generation nebula new
generation of stars each generation
having more and more elements in the
periodic table than the last
and around 300 million years after the
Big Bang our galaxy the Milky Way takes
shape
galaxies like the Milky Way formed out
of essentially a proto galactic nebula
some gigantic gas cloud that collapsed
down in formed our galaxy there is a
rich cosmic symphony playing back and
forth between stars and nebulas and we
now know that we are a part of that
symphony eventually our element rich son
is born we think that our son is a
third-generation star so it was actually
a nebula a star a nebula a star and
nebula before it became our Sun it took
around 10 billion years to create a
cosmic mix of elements rich enough to
build planets of life carbon hydrogen
nitrogen oxygen phosphorus and sulfur
these are the key ingredients to life as
we understand it and those need to be
made in stars these elements are created
during the life of a star but it takes
an incredibly violent process to
liberate them into the cosmos
an event that could be seen clear across
the universe a supernova